wir haben die neuesten meldungen hier
hinter mir sitzt tatsächlich die cdu der
cdu anteil noch zusammen es gibt noch
eine wortmeldung habe ich eben gehört
die bundeskanzlerin und
parteivorsitzende die
ministerpräsidenten müssen noch ein
bisschen warten und ich hatte vorhin
angekündigt den o-ton von christian
lindner
freundlicherweise ist er jetzt
persönlich vorbeikommen kann ich ihn
gleich selber fragen herr lindner das
ist ja heute kein gewöhnlicher tag hier
wie bewerten sie die foren lasse es gibt
in dieser ganz wesentlichen frage der
migrationspolitik keine linie der
unionsparteien und damit auch keine
linie der regierung was die spd will
wissen wir ja zur stunde überhaupt gar
nicht ich halte das für dramatisch weil
die menschen zu recht erwarten dass wir
in dieser doch sehr sensiblen frage zu
einer lösung kommen und nach unserem
dafürhalten haben sowohl frau merkel als
auch herr seehofer teilweise ja recht
natürlich wollen wir eine europäische
lösung brauchen wir eine kontrolle der
europäischen außengrenzen damit wir uns
innerhalb europas frei bewegen können da
ist frau merkel zuzustimmen
nur zwei jahre hat sie diese gemeinsame
europäische asylpolitik nicht erreicht
und deshalb hat horst seehofer doch
durchaus recht wenn er sagt dann muss
man übergangsweise das alte recht dass
bis sommer 2015 eingesetzt worden ist
wieder aktivieren wieder beachten also
an der grenze zurückweisen
genau das schlagen wir auch vor mit dem
ziel einer europäischen lösung jetzt
nach ankündigung zum alten recht zurück
das wäre ein hebel das würde den
einigungsdruck in europa erhöhen endlich
zu einer anderen gemeinsam politik zu
finden
aber warum jetzt die eile nächste woche
montag kommt der neue italienische
ministerpräsident dienstag kommt der
französische präsident und die csu macht
hier einen druck den man überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen kann warum das jetzt in
dieser woche nachdem es wie sie schon
sagten über zwei jahre so gelaufen ist
warum muss das jetzt diese woche
entschieden werden
was steckt dahinter es gibt natürlich
eine verbindung mit dem bayerischen
landtagswahlkampf das ja offensichtlich
aber dennoch ist ihre frage voll
berechtigt die csu hat das zwei jahre
alles mitgemacht hier und seit zwei
jahren müssten wir diese politik mache
ich erinnere mich dass die fdp im herbst
2015 schon gesagt haben bittet zurück zu
den alten schlechten regel von dublin
die sind besser als keine und sind die
voraussetzung dafür dass wir andere
gewinnen können zu einem fairen
zukunftsfähigen europäischen asylsystem
also die frage ist nicht warum jetzt so
eilig sondern warum erst jetzt mit
dieser brisanz und ich wünsche herrn
seehofer vtd mich v team in dem sinne
dass er frau merkel überzeugt einerseits
von der notwendigkeit zum alten recht
zurückzukehren
und ich wünsche ihm dass er den
europäischen gedanken nicht verliert
denn wir möchten keine schlagbäume in
europa auf dauer
ich hab mal nachlegen sind fast drei
jahre aber sei es drum
das ist natürlich macht kam völlig klar
horst seehofer wurde gebremst von der
bundeskanzlerin am montag und hat jetzt
die karten auf den tisch gelegt hat
gesagt im notfall mache ich eine
minister verfügung das würde ja
wahrscheinlich dann in der konsequenz
bedeuten dass frau merkel ihn entlassen
wird oder muss
macht sie das eigentlich hoffnungsfroh
für die zukunft sehen sie das als
oppositionsführer gerne nein wir möchten
dass das thema migration
schnellstmöglich gelöst wird damit sich
unser land anderen fragen zuwenden kann
digitalisierung freihandel die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung den
sozialstaat flexibel und aber auch enkel
tauglich zu machen bildung wären ja
genug wichtige fragen
diese dringliche frage muss gelöst
werden damit wir uns den anderen
zuwenden können ich glaube nicht an die
drohungen
ich erwarte leider ein windelweichen
kompromiss von cdu und csu
der so windelweich ist dass die spd
sogar noch zustimmen kann
und das wird keine problemlösung seien
leider das ist ungerecht die csu hat
hier ganz klar gemacht sie weicht nicht
zurück also den kompromiss sehe ich da
nicht und will weicht ist ja auch schon
gar nicht ich bin bereit von fall war
öffentlich abbitte zu leisten wenn ich
mich täusche und wenn nach sie haben
recht gut drei jahren die csu jetzt mal
eine klare position markiert dann lässt
sich öffentlich abbitte
ich glaube es zur stunde nichts aus
erfahrung
der bayerische löwe hat auch in den
letzten monaten und jahren geburt
passiert ist nichts
und deshalb wäre es in der überraschung
würde nun anders kommen in der sache
wäre es richtig es gebe eine kombination
aus der langfristigen zielsetzung merkel
stichwort europa und der kurzfristigen
intervention provisorisch der seehofer
vorschlägt beides zusammengenommen ist
etwa unsere position
wenn wir auf das recht zu regieren von
2015 dann schieben wir also demnächst
auch die flüchtlinge richtung österreich
österreich schrieb der richtung italien
italien schiebt dann war sie nie wohin
und hinterher fahren dann lauter schiffe
auf mittel mehr um und wissen nicht mehr
wo sie anlegen sollen ist dass sie zu
das zukunftsszenario
nein weil es ja auch nicht so laufen
würde wie sie sagen wenn deutschland
eine andere politische haltung einnimmt
und wieder zum alten recht zurückkehrt
in der tat wird es dann einen effekt
auch auf andere länder geben
mit dann der im gemeinsamen interesse
die europäische außengrenze wieder unter
kontrolle zu bringen und mit einer
kontrollierten europäischen außengrenze
haben wir auch die chance in europa zu
einer einem fairen vorteil mechanismus
zu kommen dann haben wir auch die
möglichkeit beispielsweise über
resettlement programm also
umsiedlungsprogramm wirklich bedürftigen
gruppen von außerhalb europas eine
legale einreise möglichkeit nach europa
zu bieten das nimmt den schleppern ihr
geschäftsmodell und all das werden wir
morgen im deutschen bundestag wenn es
nach uns geht es debattieren auch
möglicherweise beschließen können
zumindest eine meinungsbildung
herbeiführen können denn wir werden alle
mittel der geschäftsordnung ausnutzen
damit der deutsche bundestag in einer
sitzungswoche sich mit dieser frage
beschäftigt gut aber wenn man die lage
vor 2015 an guckt da kam auch schon
viele flüchtlinge an
da war es so dass die enormen
griechenland und italien hängengeblieben
sind man hat dann auf den drei geguckt
und als deutscher konnte man sagen ja
die sind ja nie in frankfurt gelandet am
flughafen
ich meine das kann es doch auch nicht
sein für die zukunft ich stimme ihnen
voll zu
dieses alte dublin drei abkommen das ist
aus der zeit gefallen und ist auch
rechtlich umstritten inzwischen aber was
besseres haben wir nicht und eine
unvollkommene rechtsgrundlage
unvollkommene regeln
die sind als provisorium besser als
nichts und eine andere deutsche haltung
die korrektur der entscheidung des
sommers 2015 ist nach unserer
überzeugung die voraussetzungen dafür um
mit anderen auch in gespräche
einzutreten in europa endlich in der
frage der asylpolitik europäischen
mehrwert zu schaffen
ich glaube nicht wirklich jedes detail
europäischer politik das geregelt werden
muss ehrlich gesagt da wünsche ich mir
mehr rücksichtnahme auf auch regionale
besonderheiten
aber wenn es einen bereich gibt es
offensichtlich ein gemeinsames interesse
gibt dann doch wohl kontrolle der
außengrenzen und gemeinsame asylpolitik
nachbarschaftspolitik mit afrika
das sind dort die frage wo wir alle
wirklich gemeinsame interessen haben in
einer notlage gab es kein interesse zu
helfen außer deutschland hat das keiner
getan die schweden noch die darf nicht
vergessen niederlande
aber die franzosen zum beispiel der
hammer kroell den karlspreis als großer
europäer wurde von allen gelobt die
schieben und ab und haben auch diese für
für ihre grösse wahnsinnig wenig
flüchtlinge angenommen wo ist denn das
gemeinsame interesse der europäer wenn
sie nicht immer nur auf deutschland
gucken und sagen nehmt ihr die
flüchtlinge zahlt ihr die euros also ich
sehe das nicht
ja in ihrer aufzählung muss man zu den
schweden sagen dass die unter einer rot
grünen regierung wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere 2015 bereits gesagt haben wir
machen es nicht bitte bleibt da wo ihr
seid wir helfen euch dort wir können
keine weiteren aufnehmen umgekehrt er
von fall war deutschland hat alleine
eine position mit frau merkel in dieser
frage bezogen
unsere ethischen abwägungen wollten wir
für alle in europa verbindlich machen
und dieses konzept ist gescheitert also
wir müssen nun als deutsch deutlich
machen
auch wir haben eine andere politik und
lasst uns jetzt über gemeinsamkeiten
nach vorne gerichtet sprechen mir geht
es ja auch nicht um die
vergangenheitsbewältigung aber die
voraussetzung zukunft zu gestalten wird
sein fehler der vergangenheit in der
gegenwart zu korrigieren und mit anderen
über zukunft zu sprechen so abschließend
weil sie schon lange politiker sind und
als politiker sicherlich beantworten
können wie sowas gelöst wird sie haben
ja gesagt wird ein kompromiss geben
wie kann denn das gelöst wenn die csu
stellt sich hin und sagt wir sind im
recht und montag will das von den
gremien absegnen lassen
dann kann sich eigentlich noch angela
merkel bewegt bewegen könnten sie
erraten was sie tun soll
einer von beiden wird jetzt in dieser
situation den kürzeren ziehen da geht es
bis an den politischen gesichtsverlust
es sei denn es gibt einen wachsweichen
formelkompromiss der nix in der sache
bewegt denn nichts löst er die sache
irgendwie auf der zeitachse verschiebt
wenn sie mich nach einer prognose fragen
ich tippe auf genau sowas sind sie
eigentlich froh nicht in der regierung
zu sein im moment sind ja sichtbar dass
zwischen cdu und csu bereits ein riss
besteht man hat gehört wie abfällig und
kritisch die grünen über die
unionsparteien die csu gesprochen haben
diese fraktion und unterschiede die
waren zu einem anderen zeitpunkt dieser
wahlperiode im letzten jahr in der tat
auch schon sichtbar
vielen dank christian winter war das
meine damen und herren der parteien
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp und hinter
mir gibt es ein bisschen bewegung weil
die ersten zwei drei abgeordneten aus
der cdu sitzung herausgekommen sind zum
fahrstuhl
wir gucken jetzt mal auf die uhr es ist
schon 20 44
die unterbrochene sitzung des parlaments
sollte spielens jahr um 3 uhr wieder
anfangen unten im plenarsaal ich habe
grade mal reingeguckt sitzen schon ein
paar abgeordnete aber es geht immer noch
nicht los stattdessen ist es jetzt so
dass offensichtlich auch die cdu langsam
zum ende gekommen ist das bedeutet auch
für die wartenden ministerpräsidenten im
kanzleramt das offensichtlich die
hausherren dann auch bald davor fahren
würde ich glaube nicht dass sie hier
sich den kameras stellen wird das wird
sie anderen überlassen hoffentlich dass
wir noch was mit kriegen sie wird
wahrscheinlich den hinteren fahrstuhl
benutzen und außerhalb unseres
blickfeldes hier den deutschen reichstag
verlassen also sie haben es gehört die
csu behält ihre meinung christian
lindner tendiert richtung csu und sagt
ja wohl das war früher recht das soll
wieder recht werden wir können ja nicht
einfach die menschen alle reihen lassen
und den drei so aushebeln dass es nicht
mehr
existiert die bundeskanzlerin hat
übrigens bei anne will gesagt dass diese
stadien drei systemen im grunde genommen
überholt ist ich weiß nicht genau die
formulierung mehr aber sie sagten eben
man braucht jetzt ein neues system der
meinung sind übrigens hier viele auch im
deutschen bundestag aus allen fraktionen
wir haben es auch graf von christian
lindner gehört natürlich müssen die
europäer jetzt überlegen wie sie in
zukunft mit den flüchtlingsströmen
umgehen mit einem geordneten system oder
ist man sich ja gar nicht so weit
auseinander mit einer ordentlichen
außengrenze wäre das sicherlich möglich
aber sowas sind immer lippenbekenntnisse
wenn es dann daran geht die truppe
frontex zu stärken war deutschland
damals auch einer der wenigen staaten
der dort personal und geld hin gegeben
hat ich halte noch einmal fest bei allem
deutschen streit muss man auch noch mal
festhalten dass die anderen europäer
sich hier wirklich nicht mit gold
bekleckert haben sie haben wirklich
alles unternommen dass möglichst wenig
menschen bei ihnen landen und man muss
nochmal an die ursache dieser ganzen
problematik in deutschland auch gucken
warum so viele menschen kommen da sind
auch viele menschen dabei die wirklich
aus not kommen müssen nämlich aus
bürgerkriegs gegen da sind auch viele
menschen dabei die hier ein besseres
leben führen wollen und vielleicht kein
recht haben hier zu sein
aber genau das ist die aufgabe nicht nur
des baums sondern insgesamt auch der
politik die spreu vom weizen zu trennen
und den leuten zu sagen die hähnchen
gehören ihr müsst leider wieder gehen
und dann auch die radikale abschiebung
die wurde ja auch die letzten drei jahre
auch hieraus fraktionen des hauses aber
auch in der öffentlichen meinung
teilweise
ja auch völlig abgelehnt nach dem motto
wie inhuman das denn sei
und dann kann man sich nicht wundern
wenn am schluss eben ein kuddelmuddel
entsteht und die menschen mittlerweile
auch wirklich das gefühl haben das boot
in deutschland ist voll und wir haben ja
hier eine fraktion im haus die auch
davon nicht profitiert 15 uhr 45 also in
wenigen minuten höre ich gerade beginnt
die plenarsitzung ich drehe mich jetzt
mal einmal um und gucke ob irgendwo
einer der cdu verantwortlichen sich
äußert ich sehe das nicht ein gespanntes
warten bei den kollegen ich weiß nicht
ob es sinn macht jetzt noch einmal
alexander dobrindt und markus blume
einzuspielen
oder ob wir schon mal runter in den
plenarsaal geben
ich höre die fdp äußert sich auch dann
wollen wir hören was die afg zu sagen so
etwas zeit gelassen
wir finden dass das was ich heute
abspielt in vielen bereichen nicht geht
es geht schon damit los dass die
unterbrechung der sitzung des
bundestages sozusagen nur weil interne
schwierigkeiten bestehen ohne dass wir
in irgendeiner weise gefragt werden
nicht gehen
ein ergebnis haben wir nicht insofern
ist es auch schwer ein ergebnis zu
kommentieren
es geht weiter muss man auch ganz
deutlich sagen wir stehen zu dem was wir
immer gewollt und gesagt haben dass die
grenze muss kontrolliert werden und zwar
flächendeckend das ist die voraussetzung
um überhaupt menschen zurück zu schicken
denn sonst geht es gar nicht und wir
bleiben bei dublin drei wer aus einem
sicheren drittstaat kommt hat hier kein
anrecht auf asyl und hat gefälligst
zurückgeschickt zu werden das ist
weitergehend als das was er seehofer
will aber er kann ja nicht mehr das
durchsetzen
ja wir haben jetzt heute ganz klar ein
wahltaktisches manöver erlebt das ist
eine zeit kauf politik der cdu csu
fraktion um sich noch einigermaßen den
landtagswahlkampf in bayern zu retten
und wenn er seehofer
wer die gesamte zeit über die politik
der kanzlerin mitgetragen hat jetzt
plötzlich die afg position für sich
entdeckt dann sind das alles nur
nebelkerzen
seit bestehen der afd fordern wir genau
das was seehofer nun fordert für die
landtagswahlen in bayern und was wir
sehen werden nachher ist einfach nur ein
fauler kompromiss und einfach nur
wahlkampfgetöse vorab vor den
sommerferien und da versucht sich jetzt
gerade die cdu csu fraktion in ihrem
chaos wenn durcheinander hinein zu
retten gibt es fragen was bitte sehr
also neuwahlen sehen wir grundsätzlich
gelassen entgegen weil die kfd davon
profitieren wird wir werden davon
profitieren weil das was die anderen
parteien hier abgeliefert haben war
pures chaos pure zeit kauft politik
regierungsbildung hat viel zu lange
gedauert auf steuerzahlerkosten und
schauen wir uns doch das mal an
wir haben genau die anträge als afd
fraktion bereits im bundestag im
dezember gestellt zu umfassenden
grenzkontrollen und grenzsicherung und
das haben alle fraktionen geschlossen
abgelehnt da stehen wir doch jetzt und
urplötzlich ein halbes jahr später steht
dann die csu dann da macht hier ein
riesiges fass auf ein mediales hält den
verkehr wie es gerade mein kollege
alexander gauland auch gesagt hat im
bundestag ausbremst die plenardebatten
aus so dass wir jetzt hier länger sitzen
müssen aber das ganze wird ihnen nicht
helfen man muss doch einfach nur unseren
anträgen zustimmt denn das original hat
einfach nur die lösung und das ist die
afd
eine schlechte kopie kann niemals die
lösung sein kann noch ergänzen ich
wünschte die grünen spd viel glück bei
einer neuwahl wie haben nach der neuwahl
gefragt guckt sich mal die prozentsätze
an
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass cdu
und spd gerade sehr scharf auf neuwahlen
sind
scharf auf neuwahlen ist hier sicherlich
keiner die csu hat die landtagswahl im
blick im oktober und jetzt ist auch die
sitzung der cdu zu ende gegangen und
freundlicherweise fauzy mehr zu mir
gekommen die ufer sitzen und auch
mitglied hier der fraktion die cdu hat
ja einzelnen gesessen die
bundeskanzlerin war da und
parteivorsitzende
wie ist das ergebnis na ja es ist so die
kanzlerin hat ja berichtet dass sie eine
europäische oder bilaterale lösung mit
diesen staaten wenn es um die frage von
zurückweisung und die frage was macht
man eigentlich mit menschen die schon
woanders sein asylantrag gestellt haben
wie man damit umgeht dass sie da lösung
mit anderen staaten will dass das nicht
zu lasten dritter erfolg und koordiniert
ist und sie braucht dafür zeit
ziel ist bis zum europäischen rat dort
fortschritte zu erzielen und die
fraktion der cdu teil der fraktion hat
ihr dafür auch rückendeckung gegeben
dass man sich diese zeit nimmt aber
warum braucht sie eigentlich diese viele
zeit sie hat ja über fast drei jahre
gehabt warum ist nämlich vor eine lösung
gesucht worden
wir haben jetzt lange debattiert über
die sachfragen in dieser in dieser
sitzung die wir gerade hatten aber jetzt
normal historisch zu fragen was man
vielleicht falsch gelaufen ist das war
dafür weiß nicht mal die zeit anders
ungefragt es gibt auch viele in der cdu
die die meinung der csu für völlig
richtig ansehen zurückkehren zum gesetz
von 2015
das sagt zumindest die csu nach ihrer
landesgruppensitzung das ist das was der
innenminister will er setzt damit
natürlich der kanzlerin die pistole auf
die brust kann sich die cdu eigentlich
leisten
diesem drängen des innenministers und
der csu nach zu geben denn der wackelt
so ein bisschen der schwanz mit dem hund
denn die mehrheit die cdu was wir uns
auf jeden fall nicht leisten können ist
dass dieser zustand in einer wichtigen
frage jetzt der gespaltenheit zwischen
beiden parteien fortbesteht das können
uns nicht leisten
für mich ist klar wir sollten uns jetzt
zeit nehmen das zu probieren auf
europäischer ebene sind jetzt zwei
wochen bis zum europäischen rat und uns
dann genau anschauen wie sind die
fortschritte und dann überlegen wir wie
geht es jetzt weiter mir geht es jetzt
darum dass wir diese woche hoffentlich
noch zusammenkommen um das gemeinsam zu
diskutieren
sie sehen dass alles so ruhig hier loben
vorhin auf hans peter friedrich den ich
interviewte hier außen hatte man das
gefühl es steht spitz auf knopf ist ist
also wirklich kaum noch zu retten die
situation
und ehrlich gesagt hat mir noch keiner
beantwortet wie es denn nun heute abend
oder morgen weitergeht wird es eine
sondersitzung der fraktion geben eine
abstimmung innerhalb der fraktion gibt
es viele in der cdu
die durchaus der meinung der csu sind
aber jetzt sagen also unsere kanzlerin
müssen wir jetzt schützen und unsere
parteivorsitzende vor allen dingen und
jetzt machen wir diese zwei wochen so
wie sie das ja auch schon die ganze zeit
andeuten ist da die mehrheit der
kritiker von angela merkel in der cdu
auch der meinung wir geben hier die zwei
wochen ich sehe keinen sachlichen grund
warum man nicht jetzt noch zwei wochen
warten aber die csu droht die csu droht
ab montag könnte auch der minister seine
kompetenz so das war jetzt die
stimmungslage und ich finde am ende
brauchen wir eine gemeinsame position in
dieser frage
wir sollten jetzt so aus dieser woche
nicht auseinander gehen sondern wir
müssen jetzt einmal zusammenkommen und
die dinge zusammenführen und warum bin
ich so ruhig erstens weil es hilft in
schwierigen situationen ruhig zu bleiben
die lage ist natürlich ernst aber ich
finde wir haben schon ganz andere dinge
gemeinsam gemeistert und jetzt werden
wir auch in dieser frage eine gute
lösung finden
wir haben gehört die parteivorsitzende
hat um vertrauen ihrer fraktion gebeten
da gab es ja auch auf stimmen der cdu
schon mittlerweile die frage an sie soll
die vertrauensfrage stellen
wie dramatisch stellt sich das denn im
cdu teil der fraktion da was das
misstrauen gegen angela merkel und ihre
doch sehr offene herzliche
flüchtlingspolitik angeht also weder das
stichwort vertrauensfrage noch sonst
irgendwas war jetzt thema in dieser in
dieser besprechung
sie hat ja für diese zeit noch mal hat
sie doch großen rückhalt bekommen jeden
dieser sitzung zu sagen man nimmt sich
jetzt diese zwei wochen bis zum
europäische hart und schaut und weiter
beim präsidium heute morgen hat die
kanzlerin totale rückendeckung gekriegt
einzig jens spahn hat gesagt was mir
dass die fraktion entscheiden
das ist kein geheimnis dass er da auch
anderer meinung ist übrigens wie viele
in diesem land das ist keine
minderheitsmeinung und dennoch ist es ja
so letzten endes spitz auf knopf reden
wir natürlich auch über die frage
fraktionsgemeinschaft union stellen der
kanzlerschaft einer kanzlerin in dem
fall die vielleicht der ein oder an
gar nicht mehr will auch in der union
aber die nun mal diesen posten inne hat
ist man wirklich bereit von seiten der
kritiker der csu in dem fall sage ich
mal
ihrer meinung nach sie kennen die alle
gut dieses konstrukt zu gefährden und
gar sich eventuelle neuwahlen wieder zu
finden
also ich habe niemanden hier erlebt in
den letzten tagen das war ein bisschen
herbeigeredet herr neuwahlen irgendwie
herbeirufen möchte weil er glaubt das
würde dem land irgendwie dienen das
würde dem land nicht ihn niemand stellt
die fraktionsgemeinschaft zwischen cdu
und csu infrage
deswegen sollten wir nicht darüber reden
sondern jetzt darüber reden dass wir in
dieser sachfrage und in der lösung der
probleme die wir haben mit flüchtlingen
mit migration das wird hat zum
vernünftigen ergebnis kommen und dass
die nächste woche besser startet als
diese vielleicht zu ende geht jetzt mehr
weil die zuschauer jetzt schon lange
dabei und sind und wir alle hier so vor
der tür ein bisschen miträtseln geben
sie uns doch mal einen blick die
kanzlerin war ja da die
parteivorsitzende hat um das vertrauen
geworben was ich nicht verstehe ist dass
sie auch sich im grunde wie die csu
nicht bewegt hat sie bleibt bei ihrer
position wo sehen sie denn wo hat sie
denn einen kompromiss angedeutet gibt es
da einen kompromiss na ja zu sagen wir
müssen jetzt das also dass in der in dem
ziel sind wir uns ja klar dass wir am
ende nicht wollen dass menschen
unkontrolliert und ohne papiere und
menschen die schon woanders ein
asylantrag gestellt habe dass die nach
deutschland noch mal kommen und dann
wieder ein asylantrag stellen
sie sagt ja auch dass zum beispiel
menschen die in deutschland ein
asylantrag gestellt haben der abgelehnt
wurde die menschen wieder in die
bundesrepublik aus einem anderen land
einreisen dass die zurückgewiesen werden
müssten in dem ziel sind wir uns alle
klar die frage ist wie erreicht man es
am besten und dafür braucht es jetzt
noch zwei wochen um dort fortschritte zu
erzielen und ich finde die lage ist so
kompliziert und es ist auch zu wichtig
als dass man sich die zeit nicht nehmen
sollte was mich wundert ist dieser
aufstand der csu und auch von teilen der
cdu die argumentation die man ja
nachvollziehen kann
lasst uns zum alten recht zurückkehren
die anderen europäer machen das aus weil
auch wir weisen zurück die die hier
nicht hingehören das ist ja eigentlich
auch alles sehr schlüssig da hätte man
natürlich die letzten drei jahre zwei
jahre anderthalb jahre auch schon diese
initiative starten können
und um jetzt sparen meinen schutz zu
nehmen er hat das ja auch getan hat das
immer wieder kritisiert also die
kritiker in der cdu erhalten nämlich in
den berg und dürfen natürlich auch sagen
was sie wollen aber auch der rest der
jetzt auch gerade die csu lebt heute
diese ganze entwicklung ist das nicht
doch eine sehr persönliche sache
zwischen merkel und seehofer geworden
naja manchmal entwickeln sich auch so
sachfragen zu sehr persönlichen fragen
aber das sollten wir gerade nicht tun
also mein ziel ist es dass wir gute
lösung präsentieren vor den menschen
sagen jawoll
da ist eine lösung gefunden da gibt es
fortschritte das thema migration amro
thema auch aber das thema migration
beschäftigt uns ungemein in deutschland
aber auch in europa und deswegen ist
mein appell dass wir nicht über personen
sprechen oder über persönliche
sympathien unter nicht sondern über
sachfragen und dann sind wir hoffentlich
in zwei wochen weiter so abschließend
sie waren in der sitzung was ist ihr
gefühl wie geht das weiter trägt die
unionsfraktionen gemeinsam noch die last
oder wird es zu einem bruch kommen
nein definitiv nicht das haben alle
betont wir sind zusammen und wir gehören
zusammen und wir werden auch
zusammenbleiben
ganz herzlichen dank dass sie daran sie
müssen jetzt auch unter wahrscheinlich
denn meine damen und herren und naty
plenarsitzung begonnen ich kann ihnen
noch mitteilen die kollegen sind hier
ausgeschwärmt
es gibt kein offizielles statement der
cdu vielleicht wäre eine gute idee
gewesen dass der fraktionsvorsitzende
volker kauder hier mal die
öffentlichkeit informiert wird er nicht
machen
vielleicht befindet er sich auch schon
im plenarsaal das kann ihnen gleich
meine kollegin jeannette tag sagen aber
ich darf ich noch abschließend sagen wir
haben hier einen sehr besonderen tag
erlebt und stehen hinter her ein
bisschen ratlos in der gegend rum eine
lösung jedenfalls zeichnet sich insofern
nicht ab als dass die ausgangslage
die bundeskanzlerin und cdu-vorsitzende
bitte die iren noch um zwei wochen
aufschub sie hat ja auch nächste woche
die akteure die sie braucht hier zu
besuch den italienischen
ministerpräsidenten den französischen
präsidenten dienstag und mittwoch pardon
motor und dienstag also sie bittet um
aufschub für diese zwei wochen bis dann
der europäische rat ende juni getagt hat
ja und die csu sagt also unsere meinung
ist vollkommen klar wir werden die auch
nicht mehr verrückt wir wollen rückkehr
zu den alten gesetzen
und deswegen werden wir das dann auch
durchsetzen notfalls wird der
innenminister das mit seiner minister
kompetenz alleine durchsetzen
dieses würde dann am schluss sicherlich
ein so unfreundlicher akt sein dass es
dann vielleicht doch noch zur entlassung
des innenministers kommen muss also ein
muss bei drehen nach all den stunden die
sie hiermit erlebt haben kann man nur
sagen eine lösung zeichnet sich nicht ab
und damit gebe ich jetzt runter zu
meiner kollegin jeanette klag denn seit
wenigen minuten läuft hier auch wieder
der normale plenums betrieb und vorhin
sprach mit ein paar abgeordneten die
sich selber schon sehr leid taten denn
der tag war heute ohnehin sehr voll und
jetzt hat er stundenlang nicht
stattgefunden das muss wohl nachgeholt
werden jeanette klag